welcome to no man's sky version 1.3  Atlas Rises  a graphical overhaul delivers beautiful  new environments to explore and the  universe is more alive than ever with  system wealth  economy and conflict levels admissions  can be undertaken for rewards  trading and forming are more complex and  rewarding and purchase breeders can be  navigated between systems introducing 30  hours of story and more uncover a  strange new race of travelers and unlock  the secrets of the atom terrain  manipulation allows for more complex  constructions  vortex targets unlock the ability to  quick travel to any friends  [Music]  scavengers can reprieve traitors to find  fortune  the space combat allows fighters  and note what  excited  bleaches allow travelers to explore the  universe together  and much more both follow